breaking news we understand that Dominic
Robb's future will not be determined
today we understand that Downing Street
do not intend to say either way whether
or not Dominic Rob will be continuing in
his job as Justice secretary continuing
in his job as Deputy Prime Minister the
Prime Minister has had all day to read
the QC Casey report into his behavior
his conduct those multiple formal
complaints that were made and yet here
we are towards the end of the day and
Rishi sunak has not made a definitive
judgment in the way that we had expected
that he would now perhaps he's going to
refer it to his own ministerial advisor
Laurie Magnus to as it were give it the
once over make a determination to see
whether he thinks that Dominic Robb has
breached the ministerial code but what
is absolutely clear tonight Anna is that
there is no clearly no absolutely
obvious judgment upon which the Prime
Minister can rely No Smoking Gun that
would mean that Dominic Robb was out the
door automatically this case has proved
much harder than we might have thought
this morning when it wasn't looking good
for Dominic Raab instead the Prime
Minister clearly weighing up the pros
and cons of getting rid of him the pros
and cons uh of uh coming down on the
sides of the complainant the pros and
cons uh of holding on to a guy where uh
some might come pump some might go
public about exactly what they allege he
did in the context of Dominic Robb
absolutely denying that he ever behaved
unprofessionally in front of staff so a
dramatic development because it does
point to the idea that there will be uh
more time to deliberate on the Dominic
Rob's future and that Richardson hasn't
been able to come to an easy conclusion
which I think you can only read that as
potentially being good news for the
Deputy Prime Minister
that's right Sam I guess his supporters
will see it as a more nuanced case and
the fact that he hasn't been been fired
straight off of the mark so
when might we get it I mean do you
expect that we will find out early
tomorrow morning or could this just drag
on even longer well I think there's a
little bit of reporting left to do as to
exactly how Downing streets see it um I
think there are two options either it
could be that the Prime Minister decides
that he wants to sleep on it uh and just
needs a bit more time to consider it but
that feels quite unlikely I mean it has
been at least five hours uh where in
which the Prime Minister uh has had the
report uh by Alan Tolley and he's been
able to read it and and sort of as it
were way up the nuances uh of what's
going on but at the same time it feels
like what this points to is that he
needs a if he's going to as it were
clear Dominic Robb keep him in his job
he he needs a second opinion to bolster
uh what will undoubtedly be a backlash
from those who feel like they were
victims of Dominic Rob's alleged
Behavior Uh from those that think that
perhaps the prime minister is keeping
Dominic Robb in his place for political
expediency rather than on the basis uh
of um of professional uh conduct it's a
complicated area but the fact that
there's no judgment when we know that
the premise is perfectly capable of
acting swiftly because he did so when it
came to Nadine zahawi and sacked him
hours after that report was published
into his tax Affairs he did so with
Gavin Williamson he'd sacked him uh
invited him to resign hours after uh
allegations surfaced about his conduct
Richie said that it's not like he
doesn't make quick decisions but he has
clearly decided that the decision today
that he's been thinking about sitting in
Downing Street on the basis of that
lawyer's report is too nuanced and too
difficult it does suggest perhaps
perhaps we don't know this definitively
but perhaps he is looking for ways to
keep Dominic Robb in his job and one
route could be to refer the whole thing
to a second inquiry to look to get
Laurie Magnus to look at it but
certainly we don't know uh whether
that's going to happen that would affect
the timing but no definitive decision
either way which means no departure
Dominic rub no reshuffle and no
certainty